the attack on this densely populated
refugee camp could become a turning
point in the war on Gaza The Barrage of
Israeli bombardment of residential areas
has drawn Global
condemnations the UN Human Rights office
says it has serious concerns that these
are disproportionate attacks that could
amount to war crimes the international
criminal courts Chief prosecutor Karim
Khan faces growing cuse to bring those
who commit atrocities to justice but
that won't be an easy task it is quite
clear that the Israeli pal Palestine
conflict divides uh divide has divided
the world and will continue to divide
the world um but I think that the only
way to to address that is to ensure that
there is accountability on all sides the
world's only permanent Court the IC has
a mandate to investigate four main
crimes genocide or the mass
extermination of a particular ethnic
group crimes against humanity the
widespread of systematic attack on a
particular civilian
population war crimes include among many
others the willful killing torture
inhuman treatment or unlawful
deportation and finally the crime of
aggression when a state attacks the
sovereignty Integrity or independence of
another state I don't think that the
genocidal intention is there but
certainly there are war crimes at least
on the face of it uh the indiscriminate
bombing the
starvation the ICC has said the Hamas
attack on October the 7th and Israel's
war on Gaza fall under its jurisdiction
but Israel is not a party to the Rome
statute that established the IC in
2002 in 20 2021 the Israeli government
refused to cooperate with the IC when it
was planning to investigate possible war
crimes committed by Israel in the
occupied Palestinian
territories as long as countries are
willing to uh not hold Israel
accountable and I I would Point
particularly to the United States and to
the United Kingdom in uh in the current
uh conflict um it makes gives Israel all
kinds of political space to be able to
make its own uh military and political
decisions even though they are clear
violations of uh of international law as
Israeli a strikes surge across Gaza
civilian casualties are on the rise
human rights activists fear the ICC
widely accused of political and Regional
bias may fail to deliver Justice for the
Palestinians especially when Israel has
full political and Military backing from
the US and many major Western countries
hash
Al
jaaz make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer